at the end of the day  it's not that well ultimately  women  they can't have they can't have been  [ __ ] down by so many different men and  then expect to have a man take them  seriously in a long-term relationship  it's okay making it's okay making the  man wait ever so slightly but that's if  he knows you don't have a history of  being run through by loads of different  men i think that alone is going to give  men the security to say right look i'm  now willing to wait a little bit because  i know that this woman's heart is in it  for the right reason and now i know that  i can wife her and we can do it for the  right reason we can actually have kids  and we can have a long lasting  relationship